The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AUDIENCE: Was that
going to be-- were
we going to do that
session after you do this?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: No.
AUDIENCE: [? Or ?] [? will ?]
[? we ?] do it before?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: We'll
get your questions first.
That way, I can't
time how quickly
or how slowly to go
through this lecture.
So I'd just as soon start off.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I wondered
if you could
explain in more depth how--
so, when you were--
when you're simulating
structural models,
and there's an
obvious distinction
between structural
models in which people
are forward-looking and
which people are not.
And it makes it easier if
people aren't, but it's not
as realistic.
So I wondered if you can
kind of explain like what are
the trade-offs in making people
forward-looking and then how
you--
I think there was like
a [? Vieira ?] paper
about how he was able,
for the first time,
to like get at the transition
and not just steady state.
So I didn't understand
[INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, OK, so there's
like three or four
different things in there.
It's a good question, questions.
First of all, this
forward-looking
or not forward-looking, part
of it is just tractability.
The first generation of
these models, half of them
basically assumed what's called
warm-glow bequest motive.
So you just sort of feel
warmly about passing your money
on to your kids, but,
actually, it's you,
and you are reborn
the next period.
We went through LEB,
which is this Lloyd-Ellis
and Bernhardt, which is a
simple sort of bequest motive.
So you don't take into
account the utility that's
generated by the bequest.
You just model it
as a reduced form.
It's a bit like
overlapping generations,
and that's why overlapping
generations models are still
widely used.
We had another.
There was a QJE paper on
financial volatility, which
was overlapping generations,
another one on China
and savings rates, which
was overlapping generations.
It's just far easier to solve a
two- or a three-period problem
and splice together these
overlapping generations
than it is to have a
forward-looking behavior.
So it's a judgement call.
Now Paco, way back to his
dissertation, but also then
subsequent papers with
Kaboski and so on,
have this forward-looking
aspect to it.
So not only do you
have to kind of work
backwards on your own decision
problem, but, to the extent
that prices and
wages are endogenous,
you kind of have to
forecast those too.
And, in rational
expectations, you
would require that the forecast
be rational, that households
are kind of getting
it right on average.
Actually, that reminds
me to say that one
of those flow of funds
papers we reviewed briefly
was Monika Piazzesi
and Martin Schneider.
And, although they
were using US data,
they were looking at the
effect of various things,
including a demographic shift,
sort of baby boom generation
having more young people in
the population, relatively
speaking, than before.
And they did not have the
forward-looking behavior
because they basically assumed
that the expectations you
see in the Michigan
surveys are accurate.
So--
AUDIENCE: What were
the expectations of?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Prices.
AUDIENCE: Would they go up?
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Inflation rates.
So it wasn't like solving for
an endogenous price in the model
and then having
people forecast that.
They just short circuited
the whole algorithm
by assuming that people's
expectations in the models
were as measured in the data,
even if those decisions that
got generated might
be inconsistent
with those inflation forecasts.
And it was a reminder
to many of us
how straight-jacketed
we've become,
in a good and a bad way, with
the rational expectations
because, once you have
a way of pinning down
the future via these
measured expectations,
you can expand the heterogeneity
in the model and deal
with a lot more realism.
AUDIENCE: So, in that
inflation, how far
did they forecast
inflation in the survey?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I think it
was just the following year.
So the last thing you asked
about were the transitions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Sorry,
I didn't hear you.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I was
just telling him they
measured for different
ranges of times.
I was like one year ahead
and five years ahead.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
They were concerned
with consumer durables and
housing purchases and so on.
So you'd want to
have expectations
of some of those asset prices.
The transitions are the
hardest thing to do.
You can have a model,
which is forward-looking,
and solve for the steady state.
It's like taking a little
tease off of all the variables.
So, you know, things
will settle down
to one interest rate
and one wage rate.
That doesn't mean the
decision problems are static.
People are still
forward-looking,
but they're looking
forward at those prices.
And, in a steady state,
there's always these offsetting
fractions of the population.
So some fraction become urgent.
The rest become patient.
There's always a fixed fraction.
And there's always a fixed
demand and supply of funds.
And so you get these.
And you can almost
analytically, sometimes,
get the steady state of
some of these models.
Or, even if not,
you can compute them
much more readily, whereas the
transitions, by definition,
you have a whole
path, and you have
a path of guessed interest
rates and wages and so on.
And people take that path
as given and optimized.
And then you have to
look at the excess demand
and supply for labor
and for capital
not only in the current period,
but all these future periods
for which they've
already made a guess,
and then have this algorithm to
somehow adjust the guessed path
and hope, somehow,
it will converge.
So Buera and Shin
did that originally
and have modified the code.
Yan, you've played
around with that code.
Other people have as well.
It seems to work, but it--
if you take it to
a new application,
you've got to kick it
and push it around a bit
and get scared that it's
not going to work at all.
And so it's certainly
not a silver bullet,
but it does seem to work
for particular applications.
Am I answering all--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
AUDIENCE: So I actually
have a related question.
So I remember when
we were talking
about the computation issues
in one of the extra sessions.
We were talking about
having myopic agents
and saying, well,
in the profession,
we're not that interested
in myopic agents.
But I feel like
there is potentially
some middle ground
between saying,
well, I have to
have an agent that
looks to the
infinite future, or I
have to have an agent
that is totally myopic.
And I feel like
it's actually not
more sensible to say this
agent looks to period infinity
than to say this agent
doesn't look forward at all.
So I'm wondering like
what way you see like--
is there a reason I'm not
understanding why one is
more ridiculous than the other?
Or like I mean--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
People take positions.
There's no question you're
going to get opinions.
Some people would dismiss the
myopia out of hand as outdated.
Other people are
convinced there's
a lot of irrationality
and behavioral things.
And I do think that taking
the expectations as measured
in the data is quite
reasonable thing to do.
And some overlapping
generations models
are, with realistic lifetimes
and mortality and all of that,
are really, in some sense,
the most realistic of all.
Granted, you still have to
deal with this bequest motive,
but, you know, I'm practical.
I think it depends on
the question at hand.
And it's nice to be fully
rational and forward-looking
and all of that,
but computational,
dimensional issues will limit
the model you want to analyze.
And, sometimes, it
seems unreasonable.
So I mean, for example, in IO--
I'm not sure if we'll
get to this today--
the state spaces just
expand dramatically when
you start thinking about
strategic behavior.
And then you can
actually show, if you
wanted to keep track of where
all financial providers are
going to locate with a
finite number of nodes,
kind of working
backwards and having--
that becomes a very
computationally intensive
problem.
And it seems reasonable to
say, well, let's just have them
forward-looking for two,
three periods or something,
a finite number of periods,
as an approximation.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's so interesting
because, from outside
the profession,
a lot of the criticism
we get is, oh, you
assume that these agents
are totally forward-looking
and perfectly rational.
You guys should see what
happens in your models
if you don't assume that.
But then, within the
profession, if you
were trying to
assume that, people
would be like this is
a waste of my time.
Leave me alone.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well, the
profession comes and goes
in terms of its
rational expectations,
which was kind of invented by
Muth in 1960-something I think,
late '60s.
And then it took over
macro with a vengeance,
well, in the sense that there
were a lot of unhappy campers.
So people had stakes
in doing certain--
one way or the other.
And then you need to
start putting back
ingredients in the models
to explain rigidities
and slow-moving behavior.
I mean, personally, I'm not
so sure sticky prices is
any more compelling to me than
sort of some fixed expectation.
So those are-- you'll just have
to develop your own judgment
somehow, but there isn't a
single right way to look at it.
I think it really does
depend on the applications.
And, especially, as I said, if
you want to break new ground
and explore a different
kind of model,
you may have to make
some approximations.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I have a
more general question,
sort of how to interpret one of
the classic models that we saw.
So it made a lot of sense
to me like the last part
of the other course where
we looked at insurance
and how to fit data
with different models.
But there was that one lecture
on TFP that I am kind of not
clear exactly how
to think about it
in the context of this class.
So, the paper by Zilibotti
and other people on China,
how do we--
how should we think about it
in the context of this class?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well, the
way I think about it is we're
interested in development
and development issues.
We're interested in the
impact of financial programs.
And, for both those
reasons, it seems
like we have to take
into account how
the entire economy is evolving.
People don't narrowly
stay in their village.
They can migrate.
They're forward-looking.
Potentially,
there's urbanization
going on and so on.
The starting
point-- and I put it
at the beginning, rather
than the end of the course,
was what models do we have.
Let's take an inventory of
the different kinds of models
we have to try to deal
with some of the puzzles
like why is money leaving
China while the rates of return
are so high in that
paper that you mentioned,
"Growing like China."
It is true, for example,
that a lot of macro guys
are happy sort of
modeling TFP as a process.
The business cycle
literature, following
the lead of Prescott
and Kydland,
is very much like that.
The development literature
still has those ingredients
in the sense of allowing
individual talent
and productivity
to vary, but part
of what we see in
the aggregate data
is an equilibrium phenomenon.
TFP has to do with potentially
improving allocation
of resources across
individuals and households.
So that brings us back
to the micro data.
And the way I see the
inter-relationship is I
could have equally well started
with the micro underpinnings
and built up to
the macro, rather
than starting with the macro
and then getting into the micro.
It is true, I think, that you
need to iterate back and forth.
You tend to lose the perspective
when you're just reading
macro development papers.
So what does this have to
do with the poor people
in an Indian village?
Or, vise versa, when you're
trapped in a village,
you can't see what's going on
in the rest of the economy.
I mean, it's just my firm
belief that we absolutely
have to do both.
Although, how much of
one versus the other
depends on the application.
But this is a macro
development class.
So it really has
to get us all up
to speed and comfortable
with sort of macro.
And the cool thing
about macro development
is this whole
generation of models
that's coming along that
are explicit about micro
underpinnings and potentially
testable, whereas so much
of the macro literature,
real business cycle
literature, new
Keynesian, and so on,
just make assumptions
about what's
going on at the individual
micro level and never test.
Markets, institutions, the
nature of financial contracts
are all primarily
just assumed and taken
as given in the
more standard macro
literature, whereas
development is kind
of a wonderful playground, if
you want to put it that way,
for seeing just, whether
you're going from urban
to rural areas or one
country to the next,
you can see these constraints
being estimated and varying.
And the work we did in
the class shows that that
matters for the macro.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I guess
that my point of view, maybe
also because of my background,
but it seemed to me
that, the last part, we really
were in villages like seeing
how people do risk sharing and
stuff like that and your paper
with Kaboski about the
Million Baht program.
But them it seemed
maybe we didn't
do that much on urban,
or most of the emphasis
was on the rural side.
I mean, we said some
of the implications
for the urban model and how the
data do in the urban setting.
So it's kind of a little hard
to me to go back to that macro
where we kind of
don't have firms.
Like it's unclear
to me exactly what
we're going when we're
talking about individuals
having projects.
And, oh, they might employ some
other people in the village.
But that still sounds to
me as like little things.
And then how do
we translate that
into if we think more about
it in a macro perspective
where there's really no
firms and [INAUDIBLE]??
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well, the
Kaboski paper it's true
used the annual rural resurvey.
So it's about village
and village size.
But, before we did that,
we did the paper with Alex.
And that's about obstacles.
And there we used
the annual data
for both the rural and the
urban or the annualized
version of the rural.
But, anyway, half
of the estimation
was about urban households.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I remember that.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: And so--
AUDIENCE: And we said
that the rural [? other ?]
was very important.
But it still kind of don't
resonate with me like how--
like what are we thinking
about when we think--
when we think about rural?
Are we thinking about firms?
Are we thinking about
little resalers?
[INAUDIBLE]
ROBERT TOWNSEND: There's a
whole spectrum of size and scale
of firms in these countries.
And it's true that,
in the rural areas,
they tend to be small, small
or medium enterprise, household
enterprise.
That's actually true as
well in the urban areas.
Most of the firms in
these countries are small.
Most of them don't
even hire employees.
Now, when we're
doing macro proper,
we want to make
sure that we also
include the
medium-large firms if we
have the relevant data
on them, but I'm not
sure I see so much
of a difference
between urban and rural.
For example, there are
very active money markets
in the urban areas.
Credit constraints,
in some respects,
seem as severe or at
least constrained,
very high interest
rates, money lending,
despite the proximity of
financial infrastructure.
So, yeah, you can study
urban neighborhoods.
I once did this in Chicago.
I started looking at
urban neighborhoods,
a Mexican neighborhood,
a Korean neighborhood,
an African-American
neighborhood,
and just seeing the differences
and whether the institutions
and the data seemed consistent
with certain outcomes.
So, as far as the method goes,
I don't see a big difference.
It's true that you're often
persuaded by the data you have,
and this monthly data is rather
unique to the rural areas.
So we've done more with that,
but that's just a constraint.
It's not some-- we're
thinking about, god willing,
we will gather these
monthly financial accounts
data in urban areas soon.
AUDIENCE: So, from
my perspective,
I think that, when we talk
about rural and urban,
if it's not Bangkok, urban
isn't really like urban here.
It's just like small towns.
So I wouldn't think that like--
I would think that the results
from the rural data [INAUDIBLE]
generalize to urban areas.
But when you think about--
I think your question is
more like big, big firms
or big firms in
developing countries.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so my
point is that, sometimes,
most of the time, like, when
I think about TFP and studies
about TFP, they have this
concept about TFP growth
like in a country, which
is possibly unclear
exactly what it needs.
But it's like how
much of what we're
doing at the micro level
then translates into this
like super aggregate measure?
AUDIENCE: And you
think that most of this
may be coming from
the large firm?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
I mean, I just-- again,
like China is different,
but like that one paper was
about state-owned enterprises,
which I'm assuming are big.
Like that one made
sense and was sort of--
which is why I kind of
can't reconcile the two.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: The Jeong,
Townsend paper is about TFP
at the macro level in Thailand.
And there we use
socioeconomic survey data,
which includes some
data on larger firms.
I suspect it's dramatically
under sampling larger firms.
And, nevertheless, we
explained something
like 72% of TFP movements
at the aggregate level.
So I mean that was a real
eye-opener that development
in micro is all about--
largely about macro TFP.
It's just efficiency.
You know, TFP literally means
nothing more than how much--
or, changing TFP,
how much more output
can you get period
after period, even
holding the level of capital
and labor and so on fixed?
So, to the extent that
intermediation allows a better
allocation of resources
based on individual talent,
you should expect it
to show up in TFP.
AUDIENCE: You do
have a new survey
that focuses on big firms.
Do you have any work in progress
that maybe the result is
different from what--
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Well, it turns out
that big firms are harder
to find in some sense.
They're harder to get into.
This TEPS survey
in Thailand ends up
looking a lot like
the urban survey,
even though it was designed to
try to pick up the larger ones.
I mean, there is something
called the missing middle,
and I don't know whether it's
missing because of the survey
design techniques that
are used or just missing
because it doesn't exist.
But the missing middle
refers to the sort
of life cycle of firms and the
fact that we tend to see either
the very big ones,
as in surveys, census
of manufacturers, or the very
small ones, as in household
survey data.
And the interesting thing
is, where do the big ones
come from.
What is their history?
Go back in time.
Did people move out of
villages into the town
and set up their
businesses there?
And that's something we
don't know as much about
as we would like to know.
It's even hard,
actually, to imagine
how to sample to figure
it out because everything
is endogenous.
You can comfort
yourself when you
have a fixed enumeration of
households, as in a population
census.
Then you just sample at random.
Or you have an official
registry of large businesses,
and then you sample
them at random.
So we can take
comfort that we have
an unbiased, stratified,
random sample,
but that doesn't get at
this missing middle if--
yeah.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I have another
very general question
about structural model.
So we've seen a lot of models
with this heterogeneous agent.
So, obviously, there's all kinds
of sources of heterogeneity.
And, in your model, you
only choose to model--
you cannot model all of them.
And what you're
going to model is
what you think is playing
a key ingredient in driving
the mechanism of the model.
So, for the other
heterogeneity, it's what?
Like, in the paper with
Kaboski, you just filter--
adjust your data by filtering
the other heterogeneities.
I'm just wondering whether
like, for example, people
think that there are three or
four key heterogeneities that
are driving the decision-making
at the household level,
but you're only
modeling one of them,
and you're filtering
out the others will be
getting a lot of [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Integrating up I would say,
rather than filtering out.
There is a question
of the dimension
of the unobserved heterogeneity
that's in that model
and in what we're going
to talk about momentarily.
You have-- like
an econometrician,
it's very similar in spirit.
You have the observed covariates
x on the right-hand side,
and then you have some
unobserved household
or other fixed effects
on the right-hand side.
And you can assume all kinds of
things about those unobserved
heterogeneities, but you have
to assume something basically.
It's hard to do something
completely non-parametric.
So you're making assumptions.
I'm not denying that at all.
And it matters what you
assume, but it's not
as though the
heterogeneity isn't there.
AUDIENCE: So it's
not about unobserved.
So, for example, household
[? that respond ?]
in that paper, the
heterogeneity is
in permanent income and
wealth, liquidity, wealth,
and permanent income.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
wealth might be observed.
Permanent income
is not observed.
AUDIENCE: And household
composition is observed,
but it's not modeled.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Oh, now that's
something we did for the data.
And that's more a
trade-off in methods.
Let me draw an analogy.
If you did real
business cycle modeling,
you would basically take
a trend out of the data.
I mean, in the US, there's
just this huge trend.
I mean, if you looked
at the business cycles
around the trend, you'd like
what is this subject called
business cycle.
Of course, when
you're in a recession,
it seems real enough.
So people have a filter.
You could take a
linear trend out.
You could use this
Hodrick-Prescott filter
and take out some kind
of smooth moving average.
And then, having
taken it out, you'd
just focus on the
deviations around the trend.
So what we did was take out
all the demographics, which
is not pleasant either,
but, I mean, it at least--
the other thing to do is
to leave it in the data
and use a model that
doesn't have it.
And that seems weird too.
That's like doing
business cycle modeling
and leaving the trend in.
AUDIENCE: So, id you
don't-- for example,
but, if the question
that you're--
like the model, like, if
people think that household
composition or demographics is
playing some sort of key role
in the household
decision-making,
but you're filtering it out--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: That's
a fair criticism.
AUDIENCE: So there are
criticisms like that?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah,
yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, well, it sounded like
all the research got done.
Oh wow, we'll see
you on Thursday.
No, no, those are good,
productive thoughts,
which is it's not like--
you can be sort of uncomfortable
with research in general
and the apparently
arbitrarily way
in which different
researchers make assumptions.
But where research kicks in in
a very positive way is to say,
no, I don't believe that
is a reasonable assumption.
I think it would matter a lot.
Let me try to incorporate
it and maybe leave out
some other things and see
what difference it makes.
That's where good research
is born, absolutely.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So a lot of the
models that we've covered
has a wage as a key parameter.
But, in like some research
in, if I remember correctly,
your paper in Econometrica
doesn't find a effect
on wage, at least short term.
And, also, like Esther
and Abhijit's paper
didn't also find wage,
like effect on wage,
of microfinance [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Joe
and I did find an effect
on the wage in the
astructural model.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK so that's
totally [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I missed that.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
But, again, that's
a good example again of
these trade-offs, which
is you have a sort
of a search algorithm
through the lens of a
somewhat reduced form,
maybe instrumented
variables to see what's big
and what's small.
And we found an
effect on the wage.
Now it is true
that in that model,
the structural Econometrica
paper with Joe,
we did not try to
make wages endogenous.
In fact, we allowed
investment, but we moved away
from occupation choice
and these key ingredients
of a lot of these macro models.
It's not like it
couldn't be done.
It was just something we
chose not to focus on.
AUDIENCE: I guess my point is--
so I don't think there are a
lot of evidence, especially
[? treating ?] endogeneity
of financial development.
But it seems to
me that, at least
like RCT of like
MFI and [INAUDIBLE],,
they usually didn't find,
but I only know two papers,
but they didn't find
like effect on wage.
So I'm kind of wondering
like what's your [INAUDIBLE]..
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I think,
if you think about--
you have to think about the
scale of the intervention,
all right?
So, if you have an RCT, even
with a fairly big sample,
in a small, open economy,
it's arguably true
that you wouldn't
necessarily expect
to see anything with the wage.
But, if you were scaling
that same experiment up
to the national level, then
you probably would see it.
Actually, that's a
very good argument
for doing both basically
and, in particular,
not getting misled
by program impact.
Ester's thesis in Indonesia
was about education reform.
And she was worried about
whether the wages would
go down, as you had
more educated cohorts.
So people have worried
about this kind
of thing for quite a long time.
There is some work in Canada.
RCTs are a bit sort of like
they look new, like people maybe
haven't been doing them much,
but it's not true actually.
If you can go back
into the '60s and '70s,
there was work in
Canada on I think
it was either a pension
or social security
reform where they did
exactly what I was saying.
They kind of backed
that impact locally,
and then they
extrapolated to what
would happen to the
rest of the country
if it were
implemented nationally
with the structural model.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So this is
a very broad question,
but [INAUDIBLE] asked
something about the financial
[INAUDIBLE],, especially
corporate financial [INAUDIBLE]
equity markets
and money markets.
So these markets of
course are [INAUDIBLE]
to the way economic surplus are
divided into different people
or different organizations.
So, as a result of that
[INAUDIBLE] impasse,
how, for example, new
projects or new policies
have benefited different types
of groups or organizations--
so there are some political
economy issues related
to the imperfection of
the corporate financial
[INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Impact of
the corporate finance on--
AUDIENCE: Structure on-- so
political economy concerns
about who benefits from new
policies and new projects.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well,
there's two things.
On almost anything
we've done, there
is sort of the
winners and losers.
And that, in principle,
that has nothing
to do with political economy.
That's just mapping out who's
going to get the benefits.
Now the next step is, if you
think there are barriers,
it may be that the losers
are blocking reforms.
And that's definitely
a political economy.
AUDIENCE: Oh yes,
then my question
is does the literature
seriously investigate
the second step you just
described, [? fair ?] wages.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I mean, Daron
has occupation choice models
where, basically, the
oligopolists are the ones
sort of dictating the outcome.
And they are a force
for financial repression
because they want to
keep the wages low.
I mean, that's at least a step.
We, in this class--
let me try to think if
we actually covered it.
A bit, yeah, you saw
one version of that.
We can model how financial
service providers
ought to be behaving
if we believe
the structure of the model.
Then we look at the
data, and we discover
that there are
gaps in some places
and too many banks
in other places.
And so, through the
lens of the model,
you sort of get
suspicious that--
develop a null
hypothesis that there
may be political
considerations at work.
Now how explicit or evil or
well intended it is, that's--
you have to go in
there with your eyes
open, but not
necessarily assume.
AUDIENCE: I have another
question if no one else does.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK.
AUDIENCE: So--
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Anything
but the lecture, huh?
AUDIENCE: No, I just-- this is--
so I'm kind of embarrassed to
ask this question because it
seems like it's something
that I should have been
able to figure out on my own.
But you see a lot
of people throwing
around the word structural
in ways that are confusing
and in ways that sometimes--
sort of I guess the
natural and then
from what we've looked
at and all your papers,
I guess I'd sort of be
inclined to say your models
are only structural
if you are identifying
like underlying parameters
that are in a model of interest
using econometrics or using
calibrated simulation.
But I see a lot of people
calling stuff structural that
doesn't necessarily actually
identify those parameters.
Have I got the wrong
end of the stick?
Or is there like a
nuance that I don't see?
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I don't--
I don't actually know
for sure, depending
on who's using the words,
what they have in mind.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, me either.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: I
think, legitimately,
many people are worried that
assumptions are being made
in structural models,
which are never tested,
and that you're
seeing the observables
through these
auxiliary assumptions.
And, if they were sort of
totally off and totally wrong,
then you're not
learning anything.
So that tends to push you
toward data summaries.
It tends to push you
toward not assuming things.
But then there's a flip
side, which is actually
the lecture, which is
this notion that there's
theory-free tests.
It's just not true.
Even though RCTs and--
you know, they're all
assuming some things
that you might think
are rather innocuous,
but, when you start to
think about the structure
of decision-making,
there's content there.
And those assumptions
could be wrong.
So I view the tension
that way, which
is trying to assume
as little as possible,
if you can get away with it,
in terms of the underlying
distributions of
unobservables and so on,
but, at the same time, mindful
that data work without theory
has big limitations.
And that's a debate,
philosophical and otherwise,
that goes way back, I mean,
back to business cycles.
You know, Burns and Mitchells--
Burns and Mitchell have this
business cycle measurement,
the NBER dates actually.
And Koopmans came along,
and he said it's just crap.
And there was a lot of fighting.
So how can you measure
something if you don't have
a model in mind, et cetera?
So I'm not saying there
aren't good answers to that,
but this is not just a debate
in development economics.
This is, again,
kind of a judgment.
AUDIENCE: So it's a
kind of vague question,
but we've seen in the lecture a
lot of models and evidence that
financial [INAUDIBLE],,
[? let's say, ?] sort of like
what financial development
does to the real economy.
And how would you compare
that to the situation
in developed countries?
What is like-- what
is the difference?
Because like a lot of models--
at least model-wise,
you can apply it
to developed countries.
And, at first glance,
like, for example,
like for consumption, people
aren't risk sharing quite well.
So like it's quite
close to this situation
where the market is complete.
On the other hand, if
you look at macro level,
as we saw in the first
lecture, like there's--
or like people tend to think
that financial development
[INAUDIBLE] varies
over countries
and affect [INAUDIBLE].
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Well,
we've used the US as--
some of those papers used the US
as like the benchmark standard,
as if it had perfect and
complete financial markets.
But I think we all
know now just how
badly the US and other
advanced countries
have done over the last--
since '08, '09, and so on.
So, actually, what's
going on in macro
is this huge rebirth
of interest in modeling
the financial sector.
There's no consensus
on how to do it.
And I think that
literature would
benefit from the
advances that have
been made in macro development.
But there's no reason why--
I mean, the same
issues will come up
when thinking about
the US or Spain.
I mean, Spain is an
example, for a good example,
depending on whether you think
it's an advanced industrialized
country or not.
Spain liberalized its financial
system in the late '80s
with a series of reforms
on interest rates
and the nature of business,
of savings and loans,
and all these providers.
So these little regional
banks, like Santander up there
in the north and, basically,
along with many of the others,
expanded their financial
infrastructure,
establishing branches, spreading
throughout the rest of Spain
and, eventually, of course,
on to Latin America.
And then now we have
this mess, right?
So what went wrong?
Or what went wrong in the US
mortgage crisis and so on?
So I think those are--
there's hardly a
consensus, as I said,
but those are really
important topics.
This is haunting countries, as
well as the IMF and the World
Bank and so on, now because
countries want to grow.
There's a lot of poverty,
a lot of inequality.
And there is this
notion that expanding
financial systems,
finance, can cause growth,
and growth can trickle down and
help reduce poverty and so on.
So there is this sort
of development view
that finance ought to expand
in some way and cause growth.
And, at the same time, there's
this worry that expanded,
deeper financial
systems are going
to be prone to instability.
And that's a force
for repression.
And that was the first
lecture of the class,
actually, was how do we
deal with both these,
get both these things
on the same page.
But, for sure,
today in the world,
throughout Africa
and Asia and so on,
people are sort of
wanting to expand
and, at the same time,
quite scared, as regulators,
that they're going to take
the blame in the future
when something goes wrong.
All right, so I'm going to
give you a 30-minute summary.
Fortunately, some of
these themes have come up.
And, as always,
the lecture notes
are on the Stellar website.
So it's OK if we don't cover
everything in enormous detail.
Oh, by the way, one
last thing, which is I
did write out, for
those of you who
are worried about the generals,
sort of a reader's guide
to the--
not a reader's guide, a
summary of the questions
that we've been
addressing in the class.
It's just kind of a way
to organize the material,
and I'll post that
on Stellar and--
who's also going to
have some sessions.
I think there's only four or
five of you that are actually
going to take the
generals, but, if you are,
it's easy to get lost
in all this material.
So I wrote up this
sort of summary.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[? going to ?]
need it for next year.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
Yeah, well, by then,
research will have
advanced, and we'll--
OK, so this is about
this structural
versus reduced form stuff.
And the topic is the impact of
expanding financial systems.
So it's both a methods
and a topic that basically
is the hallmark of the class.
There's three things.
I'll probably only barely
get through the first.
One is sort of IV versus
structural analysis,
all in the same
model, basically.
The second is this
expansion of banks in Spain,
which I was already mentioning,
using what the IO guys do,
the way they avoid
having to spell out
the entire structure
of the equilibrium
by using reduced form
Markov processes.
And then, finally, if
I were to have time,
I could tell you about
the limitations of that.
The point is there's
no one thing,
but you need to be aware of
the strengths and limitations.
So this is a paper
I wrote with Urzua,
and it's about occupation
choice and about
unobserved heterogeneity.
So a lot of this is
already familiar.
You've got sort of
your wealth if you're
a wage earner, your wealth
if you're an entrepreneur.
Instead of having just a
flat wage for everyone,
there's sort of this
productivity shifter,
which varies with households.
Or you can run a firm.
There's some setup
costs unobserved, again,
varying with
households, [? i. ?]
The profits come from
maximizing revenue
less the cost of inputs.
In this case, there's
no financial sector.
Ironically, I'll get there.
And you just have to finance
the setup costs and your capital
with your initial wealth.
So you saw this.
This was day two.
This was the Lloyd-Ellis
and Bernhardt model,
versions of which we
took into or modified
in some of the other
papers in the literature.
So you get to choose
one or the other.
So we can create this
decision rule, a dummy D
for do profits dominate wages.
If so, do it, and,
otherwise, don't.
OK, so it's an indicator.
Note that it depends
on observables,
the economy-wide
wage and the wealth,
which varies across households,
and these unobservables, which
are these setup costs or talent
for both being a wage earner
and being an entrepreneur.
We're not going to see those.
So, as you know,
it's sort of naive--
you know, incredibly simple,
but, in some respects,
powerful way to write
down the observable
depends on which thing you do.
But, if D equals 1,
then 1 minus D is 0,
and you have the profits
and earnings of being a firm
versus, if D is 0, you're
going to have the wage earnings
from being a wage labor.
So you can write down,
if you were running
a regression of earnings,
you could let that regression
have wealth in there and wages.
And then you'd have
this sort of dummy,
which is a 0, 1 binary variable,
plus some epsilon term,
as regressions tend to have.
However, following the
structure of this model,
we know exactly
what the epsilon is.
It's this D-weighted
average of the talent.
Now you don't change your
talent when you make an--
you have your talent in
both of those occupations.
And that's what's
driving the choice, OK?
So, basically, the
worry, correctly,
is that D on the
right-hand side is
correlated with epsilon because
that's self-selection, OK?
You choose the occupation with
which you're most productive,
and part of that choice
is based on unobservables.
So we see it both in the
choice and in the error.
OK, so we need an instrument.
Let's imagine in this economy
there's some subsidy or tax.
And it's lump sum and
administered, say, randomly.
Well, then, clearly,
the decision variable,
which has a phi in it now
is influenced by that.
And, the higher is the
subsidy, the more likely
you are to be running a firm,
other things equal, right?
But, because it's lump sum,
this instrument, this subsidy,
affects the choice of
what occupation you're in,
but it does not influence
the outcome conditioned
on choosing.
If you choose to
be a firm, you're
going get that subsidy or not.
And that leaves all the other
decisions about labor to hire,
et cetera, et cetera.
And none of those decisions,
none of those outcomes,
depend on the subsidy
because that's
sort of bygones are bygones.
You can't do much about it.
All right, so we could imagine
running that regression,
but we regress the decision
to be a firm in the data
onto observables, like
the wage and wealth,
but also onto this
subsidy as an instrument.
That's called the IV,
the instrumented version
of the decision.
And then we run the
outcome function
with the instrumented
version, OK?
So, hopefully, this is a review.
And what is the policy outcome?
The coefficient on d
after instrumenting it
is supposed to be the
gain to being a firm,
as opposed to being "treated,"
quote, and being a firm rather
than being a wage earner.
But it isn't exactly that.
Or, at least, put on
your thinking cap.
It's the local average
treatment effect.
It is the average gain in
income for those people induced
by the subsidy to switch from
being wage earners to being
entrepreneurs.
So you're not getting--
you're not getting
other things, which
are easily, similarly sounding,
like treatment on the treated.
Treatment on the treated
sounds like, oh, well, people
became firms.
What was their profits relative
to the earnings they would have
had if they were wage earners?
That's what this says, right?
What is the average in
the population of profits
with the thetas in
there less wages,
given that they made the
decision to be a firm,
and their wealth is basically b?
So I'm doing this wealth
category by wealth category.
And this is the average
treatment effect.
This is what the
average would be
if the whole population
became firms, taking wages
as given and so on.
So, basically, be careful
because LATE is not
necessarily equal to-- what
you get with the IV is not
necessarily equal to
treatment on the treated
and not necessarily equal to
the average treatment effect.
Is this a review for you guys?
OK, good.
So you can put more
structure as a way
to back out the average
treatment effect and so on.
Now this is like
assuming that those error
terms are multivariate normal.
And then you run this logistics
regression, basically,
binary yes, no, be firm or not.
And you can back out
these variance terms,
assuming that there's no--
that the talent
things have say zero
mean, or you could
adjust for that.
And then you can get
expressions for--
so then you want to basically
run your regression of profits
onto those people
who have chosen
to be firms, controlling for
their wealth and their subsidy.
And, if you didn't, if you
weren't careful and did OLS,
you'd have a bias,
but you basically
use that first stage
probit to get a propensity.
The structural
model tells you what
the exact formula is
for the selection based
on the unobservables.
And you put that
into the regression.
You literally put this into
the regression and run it.
And it, quote, "solves
for the selection bias."
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How much more
computationally difficult
is it to use some kind
of data distribution
or like some other kind
of-- because normal
is a bit of a stretch as
an assumption for a talent
distribution.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: Oh, I
think that's quite doable.
Look, this is just meant to be
an example, a classic example,
but--
AUDIENCE: Cool,
so it's not too--
OK, sounds good.
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
But, I mean, this
question that you guys were
asking, so here you've made--
you're able to get
average treatment effect
and treatment on the
treated, but only
if you make some assumptions.
And some people don't like that.
They'll say, oh, you
know, it's too structural.
But, in order to get answers,
sometimes, you need--
AUDIENCE: You have
to make assumptions.
ROBERT TOWNSEND: OK, now, I
mean, the most powerful way
to say this is we actually
see the counterfactual
through the lens of the model.
We can see what the wages
would have been for people
who chose to be firms.
By definition, they're
not in the data.
And this is a
generalized version.
And I'll just say that this is
like local average treatment
effect, but really local,
like just taking derivatives
of how that difference
between profits and wages
is going to move,
holding wealth constant,
as you vary something
like a propensity score.
And the propensity score
has, not too surprisingly,
everything to do with
those unobservable talents.
So this is hard to implement.
This one is really not easy.
Josh doesn't like it,
among other things,
but he's not disagreeing
that it's wrong.
He's just thinking it's
just not as operational.
Now the nice thing, if
you could back this out,
then you can ignore this
page, but, basically,
treatment on the treatment and
the average treatment effect
are just sort of integrals
of these marginal treatment
effects.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So Josh
sometimes recommends
to apply LATE to
non-compliance based
on observable characteristics.
So, in the typical
data set in the context
of occupational
choice, what can we
observe among characteristics
of [INAUDIBLE]??
ROBERT TOWNSEND:
So here the model
is taking a stand
that we're going
to see their initial wealth.
We're going to see the factor
prices that they faced.
We're going to see the
profits that they make.
And we're not going to see
these unobserved things that
are driving fixed costs around.
This is not the
only model around.
We're going to use the model
to make these examples.
I haven't gotten sort
of to the punchline.
I'm happy if it's
a review, but--
OK, so we have the model, right?
So, if you don't
believe this miracle,
let's simulate the
data from the model.
Instead of looking at some
of the cross-section that
got treated with the subsidy
and others that didn't, let's
take a particular individual in
the model at given parameters
and see what the behavior is,
in terms of switching occupation
and so on, as you turn the
subsidy on and then average up
in that wealth category.
So believing in the miracle is
basically the math that you're
going to see the average of
this model-generated simulation
of impact will be the IV.
It's going to be LATE
under these assumptions.
So here is the IV estimate.
And, roughly averaging over
wealth, et cetera, it's 0.45.
OLS is-- by the way,
OLS is terrible,
but I guess you don't
need to know why.
There's nothing productive
about the subsidy.
The subsidy is just
inducing people
who should be wage
earners to be firms.
Of course, the
impact is negative.
And OLS estimates
it to be positive.
Why?
Because, in the
observables, it's
the talented people
who are firms,
but they're not being
induced by the subsidy.
They're already firms, right?
I couldn't help myself.
OK, and this is the
model-generated treatment where
we actually have the panel.
And you can see, numerically,
it's quite close.
All right, so that's reassuring.
Now let's go back
to the topic, which
is what is the
impact of expanding
financial infrastructure.
Let's invent a village fund.
Let's let banks
establish branches--
forgive me for the
moment-- at random.
Like maybe the government
told them something,
or I'll get to that,
but, for now, random.
So, if we observe these travel
times or the effectiveness
of local financial
infrastructure,
we can call this cost here
to be an instrument, right?
So, yeah, so the idea is
just like the subsidy.
The lower is this
number, the more inclined
you are to incur the cost to
be able to do the banking.
OK, we rewrite the problem.
This is the part of the model
with financial infrastructure.
They get to borrow money
to cover the capitalization
and the fixed cost.
Wage earners, by
the way, also get
to put their wealth in the
bank and earn money, interest
rate on their savings.
You've seen this model.
This was, again,
the second lecture.
And now we have the
observed outcome.
If you are in--
if you chose to be in
the intermediated sector,
you have another
occupation choice problem
within that sector.
You can be a firm
or a wage earner.
These D's denote that choice.
Notationally, it's got
a w and r in there.
That r is a clue that we're
in the intermediated sector
because there's
an interest rate.
Because, if you were
in the autarky sector,
there's no borrowing
and lending of funds.
And, of course, this is
the occupation choice
we had before without
intermediation.
So we're going to get
sort of the observed
earnings in the autarky
sector and observed earnings
in the intermediated sector.
And, within both sector, there's
this other margin going on,
which is the occupation choice.
All right, now we're
reaching the point here.
We have a double margin.
There are two things
people are choosing from,
whether or not to go to the bank
and what occupation to have.
Sounds like it shouldn't
cause a problem.
This is basically--
I'm sorry this is
so hard to see,
and it must be even
harder for you than me.
I'm right next to it.
This sort of symmetric Y is
like an indicator variable
for choosing to
be intermediated.
These Y's with a little bit
of tail off to the right
are incomes under
intermediation and autarky.
It's this way in the paper,
and somehow the slides
got created this way.
But, anyway, so the gain is--
let's skip that.
So what can I say?
It's a double margin.
So you get to choose whether
or not to go to the bank.
And, within that,
each category, you
get to choose your occupation.
We can linearize the profits
functions to be functions
of the observables
and the unobservables,
substitute in those decisions,
and write out the expression
for what you see in the
data, namely, this income,
but it's just a weighted
average of all the choices,
depending on whether these
D's are 0 and 1's or these
symmetric Y's are 0 or 1's.
That was a bit of a rush,
but, I mean, I think,
conceptually, you understand
where this is coming from.
But, not only that,
look at this error term.
Oh my god, the error
term is complicated.
And it also has all
these decisions,
but note it's got the occupation
decisions in both sectors.
Depending on what
you do, certain terms
are going to kick
in and kick out.
There's massive selection
going on about whether or not
to go to the bank, based
on what occupation you're
going to choose, conditioned
on going to the bank
or not going to the bank.
And we don't see any of this.
We just see the choices.
We don't see these error terms.
So what can an instrumented
version of intermediation
give you?
It can give you the local
average treatment, the income
gains that are a consequence
of a lowered cost that
allows you-- makes you
want to go to the bank,
as opposed to what you would do
if those costs had been higher,
and you're not
going to the bank.
So the local average
treatment is the impact
on earnings that have to do with
those people who are induced
to join the banking
system as a consequence
of the placement of branches
or varied costs of access.
Now you have to be careful
in terms of what this isn't.
For example, do
we want to look--
what do we mean
when we say we want
to measure the
impact of improved
financial access on the
profits of entrepreneurs?
You want to do an IV for that?
Good luck.
Now what can go wrong?
Remember monotonicity
and independence, OK?
So monotonicity means
that more people
are inclined to do something
as a consequence of the policy
variation.
Are more people
inclined to be firms
as a function of having reduced
cost of financial access?
Maybe if they were credit
constrained and then
make a lot of money in
business, but there's
another subset of
the population,
those not so talented people who
are in financial autarky, who
would be actually induced
to leave business and put
their money in a bank.
So it's not monotonic.
The effect of improved
financial access
is not monotonic on things like
the income of entrepreneurs.
You can, if you're
careful, think
about what is the impact on
profits of entrepreneurs,
of those people
whose decision to be
an entrepreneur is not affected
by financial intermediation.
Now that's an
interesting question,
but it is not
necessarily the one
that we had in
mind to begin with.
And who are those people?
Well, it kind of depends
on their talent, right?
So you're making statements
about where these talent
cutoffs are when
you're conditioning
on, quote, "things like people
who were not making their"--
if you just run an IV
in this cross-section,
just be mindful of what you
want to do with the occupation
categories.
Now this is where the
rubber hits the road.
Am I just talking fancy
theoretical models here?
I don't think so.
This is just the
most innocuous kind
of unobserved heterogeneity.
And yet it tells you
that IV is not a panacea.
You have to be very
careful when you
use it to think
about the questions
you're able to answer.
So let me just jump.
So, again, we have
the model fortunately.
So we can generate any data
that we want from the model
and talk about
occupation choice or talk
about financial intermediation.
So, at the parameters
we put in, which
have to do with that LEB thing
you saw in the second lecture,
roughly, we can talk
about moving people
in the model from autarky
to financial intermediation,
in other words, changing
their choice problem,
damning them to autarky,
or allowing them to be
in the intermediated sector--
that's the conceptual
experiment--
and looking at what happens
to people by occupation.
So we've got guys who are
wage earners before and after.
They're not moving.
And we kind of get their gains.
We've got people who move
from the wage-earning category
under autarky to entrepreneurs
under financial intermediation,
and you'd like to
think about those
as the talented poor people
who now are able to borrow.
And then there's
this negative number.
And I looked at
this this morning,
and I'm like, [? oh, ?]
what's wrong, negative.
And then I remembered,
oh yeah, the subsidy.
So the subsidy is in place here.
So you can actually
get adverse selection,
if you want to call it that,
of people who really shouldn't
be moving from wage earner to
the entrepreneurial category.
And it's precisely
those people that
get impacted on the margin.
These are local average
treatment effects.
These are people who
are induced to change
their behavior as a
consequence of the program.
Then we've got people who
are firms no matter what,
and they gain.
And, people who are from
entrepreneur under autarky
to wage earner under
intermediation,
so these are the not so
talented guys who basically do
switch and do gain as a
result of the program.
So, I mean, so you might think
that, at plausible parameter
values, you wouldn't see any
of these occupation switchers,
but you do.
And, again, the
models that we've
been talking about sort of
assume something like that's
going on.
That's where the TFP is
coming from, except we
didn't have a subsidy.
Well, maybe China did.
Maybe we were
removing the subsidy.
OK, this will be even
shorter, but it's
a nice review in a way.
You remember that
Greenwood and Jovanovic,
the forward-looking model?
People solve stochastic,
dynamic decision problems
to maximize expected utility,
choosing how much to save
and where to put
their money in terms
of safe or risky
activities or assets.
We're going to put a little
heterogeneity in this discount
rate.
It could be other places.
Now we're just going
to experiment and see.
So here let beta i be equal to
some common average, beta bar,
and then some heterogeneity,
unobserved heterogeneity,
that makes beta i
different from beta bar.
And then we saw this
optimization problem.
We have savings,
fractions of wealth
to put in sort of safe or risky.
Or, in this case,
I generalized it
to entrepreneurial and
wage-earning activities.
You have aggregate
shocks in both.
You have idiosyncratic
You have a law of
motion for wealth.
Wealth today, fraction
saved, fraction
put into risky and safe
gets you wealth tomorrow.
We have two sectors
here, intermediated
and non-intermediated.
The non-intermediated sector
is like this financial autarky
sector.
So we're going to look for
this value function, W0.
If you're in the
intermediated sector--
oh, sorry, well,
I'll do the next one.
If you're in the
intermediated sector,
you're looking for another
value function that
solves dynamic optimization.
Now, for each one of these,
if you were there and destined
to be there forever with these
constant relative risk-averse
utility functions, you
have some simple sort
of facts like the savings
rates are constant.
Savings rates depend on
beta, but give me the beta,
and I'll give you
the savings rate.
And that's true in
autarky, and it's
true as well in the financial
intermediated sector, OK?
But, because it affects
the savings rate,
it's going to affect income.
And so part of the
unobserved error
is going to be the product
of income with this theta i,
but theta i was that preference
parameter we don't see.
You with me?
Hopefully, you can at
least conceptually see
where we're going.
OK, and so there's--
similarly, there's a
savings rate and consumption
for the intermediated guys.
And then you have
the big choice here.
This is Greenwood and Jovanovic.
So there's this cost Z of
joining the financial system.
And, if this cost Z is
sort of a random variable
in the population, it's
going to affect the choice.
The issue is whether
V is greater than W.
So, if all of this choosing
were happening only
in the initial
period at t equals 0,
then I've got a
valid instrument.
I have something that affects
the choice of intermediation,
even in this dynamic model.
And then you're in one
sector or the other.
The savings rates
depend on the error
term, which depends on theta,
but this occupation choice
here--
sorry, this this participation
choice is instrumented with Z.
And Z has nothing to do with
the unobserved preference
heterogeneity.
So I have a valid instrument.
I have monotonicity, OK?
However, that was not the
way we dealt with that model
in the lecture.
We talked about endogenous
financial deepening.
That makes households
forward-looking,
planning, potentially, to
join the financial system
at some future date.
Well, now we're in trouble,
even with the same instrument,
because what we see
prior to the selection
is the endogenous
evolution of wealth.
And these guys will be saving
up to cover those fixed costs.
It's no longer true that
the savings rates are just
constant fractions of income.
What does it mean for RCTs?
It means you should
try to keep the control
population in the
dark about the program
because, if they
know it's coming,
and they'll eventually
get treated,
they're going to change
their behavior if they behave
the way they do in the model.
So Ben surprises people
with the road construction
when he dug up the dirt to see
what the pavement was made of.
That happened after the fact.
He didn't tell them he
was going to do beforehand
for obvious reasons.
But it's very hard in the
field to maintain this
because people want
to know why they're
answering all the questions
in the questionnaire
and not getting the program.
They're not even supposed
to know about the program.
You know, there are
ways to try to fix it.
Now it's true that, if
you had like a surprise,
even though they're
following this dynamic model,
you say, oh, today is
we got a special deal.
It's not going to be
repeated tomorrow.
Then you have this
one-time-off experiment.
You have this Z that's lowered
that they got surprised,
that prior behavior isn't
influenced by it, that will
induce selection and so on.
Well, what am I doing?
I'm just reviewing, in a
way, what we've already done
with these kinds of models.
This one is dynamic,
but putting it
in the language of when RCTs
and instruments will work
and what to be kind
of leery about.
I honestly don't see how you
can talk about IV or RCTs,
random as they may
be, without having
some framework in your head
to think about the model.
And the rest I'll skip.
It's about that financial
expansion in Spain.
I'll tell you the key
insight the IO guys had,
which is, basically, you
worry about an equilibrium
where everyone is
anticipating everybody else.
You say, well, hey, if you
believe it's an equilibrium,
then it ought to be in the data.
So you start running
reduced form regressions
of how your competitors behave
as a function of what you did.
And that's kind
of the forecasting
aspect, which you can bring
into the individual problems.
I know it sounds a
bit counterintuitive,
but, basically,
the reason it works
is because everyone is
getting these shocks.
So no node-- you know,
you can be at any node
and go to any other node
because there's always
a shock that's going to
rationalize that choice.
It's like Hutz and
Sedlacek way back when.
And it's the foundation of
these discrete choice models.
Now that doesn't always work.
And the last thing I
won't even tell you
is a situation
where it might fail.
So the point was
not to drive nails
in the coffin of one
way of doing business.
The point was to have
an open conversation
and have everything
on the table and so
to increase our sensitivity.
If you don't think
heterogeneity is--
unobserved heterogeneity
is a big deal,
that would help you
a lot, but, when
we looked at the
impact of microcredit,
we saw a lot of
heterogeneity in outcomes,
whether it was Hyderabad
or Thailand or Morocco.
That seems to suggest this
selection on unobservables
is quite important.
OK, good.